What are the best cellular detox supplements?
Well, I think when you talk about cellular detox,
you're talking about what I call phase zero detoxification pathway.
And I list this out in my seven phases of detox book
and my seven phases of detox video.
And my seven phases of detox course.
And I don't want to be just thinking and trying to upsell you guys on everything.
But there's a lot of information in these courses.
And there's a lot of information that we need to know about the physiology of a question like this.
So I'm going to try to go quickly on this.
So you have really seven phases of detoxification.
We need let's start with the end.
Okay.
And the end is you depositing things in the toilet.
I call that phase six.
If you're constipated or you're not having good bowel movements,
you have no business trying to detox cellularly until you get that cleared up.
And then phase five is what is your intestinal rate of elimination?
What is your elimination rate?
Meaning if I eat corn today, do I see it in my stool tomorrow?
If it takes three days to see it in my stool, my intestinal transit time is extremely slow.
If I am a intestinal transit time that's slow, even though I might have daily bowel movements,
I'm reabsorbing a lot of poisons in my intestinal tract, particularly the large intestine.
If I'm reabsorbing my poisons in the large intestine because my intestinal transit time is slow,
I'm debuting the purpose of everything as far as detoxification.
So I have to make sure my intestinal transit time is healthy.
I'm not eating and have to run to the bathroom, I have diarrhea.
But I'm eating and noticing what I ate that is indigestible, an indigestible starch or fiber that I ate in the toilet,
in my feces the next day.
I should have that, that should be the intestinal transit time, the rate of what's going through my gut.
That I call phase five.
So if I'm reabsorbing poisons in my gut, then I need to deal with that before I have any business of trying to pull stuff out of my tissues.
And then the phase four is, how is the health of my gallbladder itself?
So my gallbladder itself, we could even include my pay grace health in that.
How is the health of that? Is that sluggish?
If that's sluggish, I need to deal with that.
So again, I go into greater detail in my book and my course, my detox course on this.
And then phase three, two and one is in the liver.
That's what you'd read about in your physiology book if you've taken, if you remember biology, human biology.
If you've taken a course of that, you'll read a phase one, two and three that takes place in the liver.
So blood goes through the liver and then through phase one detoxification pathway.
It pulls toxins out of the blood and it goes through phase one.
Then phase two, phase three, it's bound to bile.
It goes into the gallbladder, that's phase four and into the small attested and phase five.
Hopefully you're not reabsorbed anything of phase six, you're deposited into the toilet.
So how does it get into the blood? Well, it gets into the blood first by consuming it.
Or you read it in a toxic that goes directly into the blood.
Hopefully it's going to get filtered right out of the liver.
The problem is that you have congestion in the liver, slow phase one, two, three pathways.
Overwhelmed phase one, two, three pathways.
So it circulates again. It circulates again.
Then finally, we'll get dumped into the tissue and then commonly gets absorbed into a fat cell and do your cells.
You can go into any cell.
But fat cells, I always say, have the spiritual gift of accommodation.
They welcome anybody in.
They take in a lot of toxins, but it could go into any cells.
And then toxicants can cause damage to the nucleus and the damage to the nucleus can be answered.
That's what cancer is.
Is nucleus replication rate, replication replicated cells, that's cancer.
Have to make sure our deep thought is, well, go to six out of my cells.
That's all that phase zero.
How you would use a body of your cells, you'd use it later.
So key later, ETA, DMSL.
There's a lot of different.
You have no business doing that if your phase two, phase three in the liver,
because it'll just get dumped somewhere else.
So when you're healing the gut, you know, from the top down.
When you're much slower than I did right here.
And that's how you would eventually then pull stuff out.